[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
coach joins us now coach congratulations
if i would have told you when you were
in greece
that you were going to eventually come
back to the states and take a team to
the ncaa tournament what would you have
told me
uh it it would be possible uh i just i
probably would never have figured out it
was gonna be iona
uh but i was i was really really happy
in greece and
things were going well so i i wasn't
really thinking about going there until
the president and the athletic director
flew to madrid
how do you explain what has happened
let's say in the last
three years if somebody didn't know just
the cliff notes version
how would you explain your life in the
last three years of what has happened
and where
you know how you got to where you are
today
well you know it is there's there's so
many great things that happen in a span
of
40 years of coaching but it is a roller
coaster
and my roller coaster went extremely
high
it would be like the cyclone at the old
coney island
and it's extremely high and then it got
extremely low
but i think if you pick yourself up and
not
not that i didn't do that but for about
a year and a half i was extremely bitter
at certain people
and now i'm not bitter at anyone so it's
you move on
uh you pick yourself up and you you try
to make something special where you
where you're at
how do you get rid of the bitterness
i get rid of it by stop pointing fingers
stop stop uh
blaming people that weren't louisville
people on the board of trustees i
i still i was blaming um disloyal
assistants how could they ever do such a
thing
and then in the end i just took
responsibility by looking in the mirror
i said hey
you hired those people it's your fault
and then uh the bitterness for the other
people and so that that's
i i finally came to the conclusion and
said if this happened
and i was on the board of trustees i'd
fire myself as well
so you just you just get down to reality
and you speak the truth
the only way you get better is to own up
and not make excuses and i just finally
owned up it took me
uh way too long i wish it would have
happened sooner how low did you get
um you know
i had an awesome job for 17 years and we
had it rolling
three final fours a championship and so
when when all that's taken away from you
and you're in greece by yourself
you get pretty low but the second year
in greece was so spectacular
that's when the bitterness dissipated
and i just had the most wonderful time
learned so much
basketball that i didn't know in terms
of different styles of play
met so many incredible people in greece
that i'm the national coach now i'm
still close with
uh so many people my agent over there
has become one of my best friends
so in the end you look back and say hey
it was a new frontier but
but it was really really a special
frontier
has your coaching style changed just
you know what i learned euro league
basketball they're not as talented as
the nba but a lot of nba players
had to tell him their career a play over
there dominique wilkins played for the
team i coached uh byron scott played for
the team by coach tony delk
what happens is you have terrific
offensive basketball
it would look like princeton on steroids
in terms of the passing the ball
reversal
the bounce passes the movement the
shooting is great
with bigger better players than
princeton and then
the defense is not as good as the nba
obviously but then you traveled into
tel aviv and moscow and petersburg and
germany milan barcelona madrid
istanbul uh some with fantastic some i
don't want to go back
[Laughter]
where do where don't you want to go back
to
i don't want to get killed saying
so so moscow or istanbul you might not
put on your uh passport again
moscow i loved okay we loved
was in the red square and uh you know
these people come up to you in their
costumes and take
pictures it's all about money again just
no different than any other place like
42nd street but the mall surrounding
uh red square is fantastic
moscow i loved very clean now traffic
in moscow and istanbul is la times five
where's the strangest place you were
recognized
uh probably moscow
probably moscow uh because basketball's
not that big there it's
it's uh hockey and soccer um
and the guy we would have the staff was
having a beer at this place a guy came
up to me and said
i see you all the time you're an actor
and i said uh well some people believe
that
no i'm not an actor i said i'm a
basketball coach
that's where it is wow
well that's good we're talking rick
pitino the iona head coach as uh
iona won the uh mac championship and
they got number two alabama coming up
saturday at four eastern
what are the analytics on uh
three-pointers now since you sort of
ushered in this era
uh you know when you were at providence
but
where are we now do you think i think
alabama
is is probably epitomizes where
it has arrived because they totally at
forty percent of their shots are threes
then four another forty percent are at
the rim
eighteen percent they get fouled and two
percent is mid-range they
absolutely wanna cut out the mid-range
shot completely from their repertoire
so that's where it has arrived for for
alabama but
what people don't recognize what makes
them so great is they're also top three
um defensive team in the nation adjusted
defense so they play
fast but they play awesome defense with
great length
now if they if it was just a three-point
shot of just getting to the rim with no
mid-range game they wouldn't be quite as
good
but they were awesome and in 87 when we
started
shooting more threes and everybody i i
told my guys that well if you make
uh if you make so many a 10 10 threes a
game and you give up nine it's not a
weapon
so i said we've got to make seven eight
threes a game but we've got to keep our
opposition to two or three
for it to really get the fruits of your
labor
and then what loyola marymount did with
paul westhead
but did was he taking what you you
started
and then just kind of you know like well
paul also beat everybody down the floor
with and got a lot of layups no question
about it
uh paul was a great offensive mind the
only difference is is
loyola didn't play great defense they
were decent but they didn't play great
defense
and what makes out not only alabama play
great defense but they have great length
great athletes uh they rotate terrific
so they're they're a legitimate team to
win it all and
there's about eight or nine of them out
there none i think the likes of gonzaga
but there's about eight or nine of them
uh the protocols that you had to deal
with
um you know that something new for
everybody but how wild was it when
you're not quite sure if you're going to
play a game or have a practice or how
many players you're going to have
well we probably were paused more than
anybody in college basketball we missed
55 days of practice pause four different
times
i didn't know dan if we were going to
play in our conference tournament
because
we swept monmouth in a two high scoring
games and
isaiah ross our best player had 31
points that night he went on the
computer
to check out his uh thursday test and he
had covet he played with covet
he was asymptomatic the whole team went
back into pause we came out and five
days
later we had to play a game and our ad
and i said is there any way you could
get them ready in five days i said i'll
try but
it's going to be difficult and we went
double sessions we went an hour and 20
minutes in the morning
an hour and 20 at night and why only an
hour 20 because if you go any longer
you're going to
pull a grind and pull a hamstring so we
got into we're still not 100
in shape but we're getting there another
two couple of weeks and i think we'll be
there
i know that you're on record you're
saying you're going to retire at iona
right yep 100 if indiana cold would you
listen to indiana
i've had a few calls from people about
and i'm not saying indiana about other
situations and i told them look
i'm i'm honored i'm complimented uh but
i i
you see them when the president and the
athletic director flew over to iona
i tried to because he was the uh he was
the president of transylvania a small
school
right next to the university of kentucky
i tried to explain to him what went on
at louisville and how i had nothing to
do
he interrupted me wouldn't let me go 10
seconds white said coach
we've already spoke to all kentucky
officials we spoke to the louisville
lady
we spoke to seven players you coached at
each school
that we have already done our homework
we wouldn't have flown 16 hours here
if we didn't do our research so don't
even bring it up again we want you to be
our coach
when he said that i wasn't sure i was
going to take the job i
immediately knew in my mind i was with
my son my nephew and my niece
and in madrid and i immediately
knew i was taking that job so i have no
interest in any
place anywhere um would i like to
someday go back to the euro league and
coach there again if i own a ran out yes
i would but outside of that
it's just retirement okay
i'm recording this you know uh i've been
on record quite a bit so
okay it would be a waste of time for
anybody even to pay me the compliment
to uh to have consideration because
you your loyalties are important when
you're 68 i think when you're 35 you're
looking to move up the ladder
uh i'm not looking to get on top of that
roller coaster anymore i'm i'm having a
blast coaching young men
that have the same ambitions that my
kentucky players had on my providence
play at louisville
and they have the same ambitions maybe a
little bit lower it's not the nba it's
the
champions league over in europe but they
have the same ambition they have the
same potential to get there and i'm just
flat out enjoying a small little
catholic school in new rochelle new york
but are you managing
i mentioned coaching are you coaching
different are you managing your team
running a program with
what happened at louisville do you look
at the program
differently more hands-on with things
you know dan i i've had 30 30 assistants
move on to be head coaches either
players or assistants move on to be head
coaches
some of them the big names in basketball
so tubby smith won a national
championship
uh billy donovan's with the bulls and
jim o'brien went to the celtics the
paces in the sixes
so at the frank vogel was my student
manager at kentucky
i've had so many wonderful people have
gone on to great prosperity and success
uh then i made a couple of hires that
things were done behind my back
i trusted people but i don't want to get
paranoid with my staff right now and
like one ncaa guy said did you look at
his computer
i said well first of all sir that's a
felony and second of all no i did not
and so i don't want to get paranoid and
do that but
i'm certainly on top of every little
thing regardless whether it's iona or
kentucky you have to be that way today
i think you should bring back the white
suit
definitely a new rochelle um there's a
lot of people walking downtown with
white suits on
except they're probably uh in a
different profession than coaching
basketball
yeah but you could be in the medical
field maybe arthur avenue in some of the
gangsters do you still have that white
suit
i do i wear it at a prime 112 in miami
yeah you can fit in there hey um good
luck with alabama
see what you created these teams that
shoot threes now you got to try to
defend that good luck with that coach
and um
congratulations again thanks dan good
visiting with you
that's uh rick patino the iowa head
coach